la plus travaillée des noms travail oit
pour obliger les soins d'eau pardon
pourquoi obliger des soignants de se
faire vacciner cieux vous savez très
bien qu'il s'approvisionne pas monsieur
comment en vie s'il vous plaît laissez
nous reprendre le travail on a besoin d
être amené avec moi d'abord le mieux ça
ne peut pas me filmer dans la mare
courtoisie plus que moi je suis je viens
vous voir gentiment mais je comprends
d'autant pour moi votre émotion là en
tout cas le gouvernement à court terme
il va pas empirer va pas enlever
l'obligation vaccinale
c'est moi travailler
mais aurait manqué de temps à penser moi
alors deux choses j'ai d'abord j'ai bien
aimé quand il lui a dit vous ne filmez
pas ça ça j'ai bien aimé parce que la
fille elle est perdue elle le film s'en
rend pas compte et d'ailleurs à ses
excuses tout de suite donc ça j'ai bien
aimé de la part d' emmanuel macron
ensuite je trouve vraiment vraiment ils
se rendent pas compte c'est dégueulasse
ce qu'ils font il prend l'argument de
dire vos collègues sont vaccinés à 95%
mais les 5% comparé voulu se faire
vacciner là on sait très bien que nous
on vit normalement on a plus de masques
on peut aller en boîte de nuit on peut
aller à n'importe qui
puisque je rentrerai pas il ya comme une
espèce de le covin n'existe plus
maintenant c'est la guerre en ukraine et
on dit quand même aux soignants vous ne
continuerait pas à travailler et ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
soignants non ne cumule pas de congés
payés donc ils n'ont pas de congés payés
ils n'ont pas d'indemnités ils ont rien
ils n'ont pas droit au chômage ils ont
rien c'est comme si doute vous demain on
vous prend et on vous dit comme t'as pas
mis ce vaccin dans le bras qui selon eux
ne sert strictement à rien tu n'as plus
rien tu n'as plus de revenus d'argent et
c'est quoi ces eaux on est où là on est
où elle avait un travail la fille
pourquoi tu mets enlever son travail
maintenant que tout va bien tout est
rouvert on a des restrictions encore je
dirais il ya encore des restrictions
mais la rendait leur rendez leur leur
boulot arrêtez rendez leur leur boulot
c'est pas bon à moi je trouve qu'il ya
aucune logique comme il ya eu beaucoup
de décisions parce qu'en fait il ya une
dérogation pour le personnel soignant
positif s'il ne touche pas et s'ils
n'étaient renie pas déjà rien que
d'écrire cette phrase je ne sais pas qui
l'a écrite mais c'est complètement idiot
donc sachant ça je ne comprends pas
pourquoi on n'accepte pas les gens qui
ne sont pas vaccinés ça sans que la
vaccination n'empêche pas la
transmission et la bla bla je suis
désolé excusez moi donc moi je dis que
je ne comprends pas cette décision il
faut remettre les gens au travail là que
quand on voit la détresse de cette femme
ça ça ne sert à rien l'ex is lex la loi
c'est la loi dans l'attenté de la suisse
et l'alsace lex sed
lex
[Rires]
la loi c'est la loi paris dont ça a été
décidé comme ça on a un président il est
encore président il a décidé que n'avait
pas de travail et voilà on suit ta ux
qui lui a dit 95 % de vos collections
vacciner personne n'est mort soyez
d'actionner ses vous aurez votre boulot
en france on adore discuter discuter i
nia nia nia voilà il ya la loi elle est
parée pour tout le monde un gérant
divine en fait j'entends les deux
j'entends mathieu et j'entends le loup
le renard et la belette
parce que le big assure vaccinale par
exemple des soignants a été établi en
italie au royaume-uni en belgique et là
j'ai vu que le royaume uni par exemple
faisait machine arrière il a estimé que
c'était plus la peine après on est en
campagne électorale macron il lui reste
quatre semaines il a pas envie de
changer de cap on peut pas lui justement
leur projet d'être démago nous d'être
voilà face à des pleurs il n'a pas
réagir en disant oui au cas par cas
voilà c'est une règle générale et moi je
trouve que la règle générale il faut la
respecter ça me choque pas plus que ça
même si je conçois que individuellement
quand on voit cette femme pleurait
effectivement c'est poignant bien sûr
moi j'ai confiance en la médecine
toujours j'ai confiance dans le vaccin
est le mécanisme compte il ya beaucoup
de qu'en ce moment il ya une
contamination soignant soigné ses
risques et malgré l'étude il alors tu
dis qu'il vais pas faire marche arrière
pour pas être démago mais de d'annoncer
à trois semaines la présidentielle qui
va renault a augmenté lundi des
fonctionnaires que tous les
fonctionnaires seront mieux payés plus
de six millions de fonctionnaires alors
ça n'a pas bougé mais disons il pouvait
le faire pendant son quinquennat et
c'est démago
en disant j'enlève le pass vaccin
la belge âgée
de
10 ans si j'ai la nuance près
qu'aujourd'hui dit que le président ne
change pas de cap m'enfin bon à un an
pour les soignants tout pour te dire un
mois du premier tour il enlève quand
même les masques alors que maintenant il
ya recrudescence de cas donc c'est
bizarre tu ne dis pas c'est c'est
peut-être aussi par rapport au premier
tour nombreux choix d'un dôme en plo
norme par rapport aux élections et
pourquoi la manette en fait on estime
que c'est moins grave en fait tôt mikron
est que après tout si on shoppe omicron
ça fait une immunité comme tous les
médecins nous ont dit si quand ils sont
venus mais les graphies un siècle voilà
on a une immunité c'est très bien comme
ça on sait vacciner il ya une immunité
tout va bien voilà voilà l'écart prenne
et c'est là qu'on assoupli tout alors
qu'on est à un mois du premier tour est
clairement une fois qu'il sera réélu il
remettra dans
les jambes alors guillaume quand il a
levé le pass vaccinale moi j'ai cru à un
moment qu emmanuel macron l'emmerdé plus
les non vaccinés mais en fait si on peut
dire qu'ils les emmerdes toujours un
cette vidéo est ligne en inhumanité
terrible et non vaccinés d'un côté une
dame qui est dans une détresse terribles
qui ne peut plus travailler et qui donc
qui a du mal à vivre et d'un autre côté
un président qui passe qui dit bonjour
on n'est pas vacciné salut j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] non mais dites étoiles âgées
n'est pas pareil non mais
j'ai vu tomber la gagne on est alors
elle n'a pas droit de vivre jusqu'à
quand va lui pourrir la vie de ces gens
là c'est horrible ce qui s'est passé
sinon ce que j'ai dit ok on vous est
hallucinant je suis imaginé un président
de la république qui sous la dictature
de l'émotion 10 à cedar a oui vous avez
raison je change de cap mais enfin à ce
moment là il sera un président fantoche
qui tue même de ses idées mais c'est
impossible guillaume mais c'est bien sûr
qu'il ya un contraste entre la douleur
et le côté réaliste mais il est
président de la république il incarne la
fonction il peut pas succomber aux
larmes d'une dame c'est impossible et
deux civils demandez ce soir à marine le
pen si par exemple elle veut une
obligation vaccinale pour les soignants
de vacciner ou pas c'est à dire ksk
l'inversé on se réfère au passé une tête
vous
permettrait pas mais c'est intéressant
parce que justement les gens se
positionnent pour rencontre mais bien
sûr non merci
je voulais non mais c'est pas d'émotions
il s'est passé pas un caprice et sa vie
elle ne peut plus travailler et comment
tu peux entendre aujourd'hui alors on
dit à tous les français lever le masque
on en a plus rien à [ __ ] sortait aller
en boîte de nuit prôner l'abandon voyage
et c'est à cette pauvre dame comme on
peut le dire vous ne pouvez plus
travailler non mais c'est pas du cadre
si c'est le cas dans ce cas que ben oui
c'est pas du cas par cas c'était toi un
jour tu es bien cette émission c'était
choquant les lois faut faut les suivre
ou pas les suivre s'il faut les suivre
ses pas du cas par cas elle est très
très cette dame mais encore une fois lui
ai dit que 95% des gens sont vaccinés si
tu n'es pas d'accord avec ça dans quatre
semaines tu votes sur un autre résident
peut-être la loi c'est celle d'un
président démocratie tu peux voter pour
t'exprimer c'est pas effectivement c'est
pas la dictature de l'émotion ou comme
on l'a vu l'autre jour et je t'envoie
1,9 et machin c'est pas ça la loure la
loi